SECOND NIGHT Well, you've made it through, she
said, holding both my hands tightly.
I've been here for the past two hours.
You have no idea what a state I've
been in all day.
I know, I know.
But let's get down to business.
Do you know why I came?
Not to talk nonsense like yesterday.
Here's the thing.
We need to act more sensibly from now
on.
I thought a lot about this last night.
In what way?
What do you mean by more sensibly?
I'm ready to do my part, but honestly,
nothing has ever seemed more sensible to me
than this.
What's happening right now?
Really?
Well, first of all, please don't squeeze my
hand so hard.
Secondly, I have to tell you, I spent
a lot of time thinking about you today,
and I wasn't sure what to make of
it.
And?
How did it end?
Well, I realized that we have to start
fresh, because after thinking it over, I concluded
that I don't know you at all.
Last night, I acted like a child, like
a silly little girl.
I've decided it's my soft heart that's to
blame.
That's what we always do, isn't it?
We analyze our actions and end up excusing
ourselves.
But to fix my mistake, I've decided I
need to learn everything about you.
Since there's no one I can ask, you'll
have to tell me yourself.
So what kind of person are you?
Come on, start from the beginning.
Tell me your whole story.
My story?
I repeated nervously.
But who said I have a story?
I don't have one.
Then how have you lived if you don't
have a story?
She asked, laughing.
I've lived without any story at all.
I've lived keeping to myself, completely alone, utterly
alone.
Do you know what it means to be
alone?
Alone?
What do you mean?
Do you never see anyone?
Oh, I see people, of course.
But even so, I'm alone.
What?
Do you mean you never talk to anyone?
Not really, not in any meaningful way.
Then who are you?
Explain yourself.
Wait, I think I know.
You must be like me.
Do you have a grandmother?
Mine is blind, and she never lets me
go anywhere.
I've almost forgotten how to talk to people.
Two years ago, when I got into trouble
and couldn't be controlled, she made me sit
with her.
She even pinned my dress to hers, and
now we sit like that every day.
She knits stockings, even though she's blind, and
I sit next to her, sewing or reading
aloud.
For two years now, we've been stuck like
that.
It's such a strange habit.
My God, how awful!
No, I don't have a grandmother like that.
Well, then, if you don't, why do you
stay home all the time?
Do you really want to know what kind
of person I am?
Yes, I do.
In the strict sense of the word?
In the very strictest sense of the word.
Very well, I am a type.
A type?
What sort of type?
the girl exclaimed, laughing as though she hadn't
had the chance to laugh in a whole
year.
Yes, it's so amusing talking to you.
Look, here's a bench.
Let's sit down.
No one will walk by here.
No one will overhear us.
Now tell me your story.
Don't try to deny it.
I know you have a story.
You're just hiding it.
To start with, what is a type?
A type?
A type is someone original.
It's a ridiculous person, I replied, catching her
contagious, childlike laughter.
It's a character.
Listen, do you know what it means to
be a dreamer?
A dreamer?
Of course I do.
I'm a dreamer myself.
Sometimes when I sit with my grandmother, all
sorts of things fill my head.
Why, when I start dreaming, my imagination runs
wild.
I've even married a Chinese prince in my
dreams.
But sometimes dreaming is a good thing.
Though goodness knows it's better when you have
something real to think about instead, she added,
her tone suddenly more serious.
Wonderful.
If you've been married to a Chinese emperor,
then you'll understand me perfectly.
Come, listen.
Oh, but wait a moment.
I don't even know your name yet.
Finally!
You sure took your time thinking of that.
My goodness, it never even occurred to me
before.
I felt perfectly happy without knowing.
My name is Nastenka.
Nastenka.
And that's it?
Nothing more?
Why, isn't that enough for you, you insatiable
person?
Not enough?
On the contrary, it's more than enough.
A great deal, actually.
Nastenka, you kind girl.
If you're Nastenka to me from the start,
that's all I need.
Exactly, well.
Well, listen, Nastenka.
Here's my ridiculous story.
I sat beside her, put on a mockingly
serious expression, and began speaking as though reading
from a book.
There are, Nastenka, though you might not realize
it, strange little corners in Petersburg.
It's as if the same sun that shines
on the rest of Petersburg doesn't reach these
spots.
Instead, they seem to have a different sun,
one made just for them, casting a unique
light on everything.
In these hidden corners, my dear Nastenka, life
is very different from the bustling world around
us.
It's a life that seems to belong to
some far-off, unknown place, not to our
overly serious times.
This life is a mix of the wildly
imaginative and passionately idealistic, combined, unfortunately, with
something drab and dull, plainly ordinary, if not
downright vulgar.
Wow, good heavens, what an introduction!
What am I hearing?
Listen, Nastenka.
I feel like I'll never get tired of
calling you Nastenka.
Let me tell you that in these little
corners strange people live, dreamers.
A dreamer, if you want an exact definition,
isn't really a regular person.
There's something in between.
Most of the time they settle into some
hidden, unreachable corner, as if they're trying to
escape the daylight.
Once they find their little spot, they stick
to it like a snail, or maybe more
like a tortoise, that odd creature which is
both an animal and its own house.
Now why do you think they're so attached
to their four walls, which are always painted
some dull green, dirty, gloomy, and always smelling
horribly of tobacco smoke?
And why, when one of their rare acquaintances
visits them, because eventually they manage to drive
away all their friends, why does this strange
person greet them with such awkwardness?
They seem embarrassed, their face changes, and they
look like they've just committed some crime within
those four walls, like they've been forging fake
money or writing poems to send to a
magazine, pretending the real poet has passed away,
and they feel obligated to get the work
published.
Why tell me, Nastenka, is it so hard
for these two to have a normal conversation?
Why is there no laughter?
Why does the visitor, who might otherwise love
to joke around and chat about light-hearted
things, like women or other fun topics, suddenly
fall silent?
And why does this visitor, who is probably
new and making their first visit—because, trust me,
there won't be a second—why does even this
friend become so uncomfortable and tongue-tied, even
if they're normally witty?
It's as if they're trapped by the gloomy
expression on their host's face.
And why does the host, in turn, seem
completely lost, desperately trying to liven things up,
show some charm, and talk about cheerful things
like women to make the visit enjoyable?
And why does this visitor, suddenly remembering some
urgent task that doesn't really exist, grab their
hat and hurry to leave?
They pull their hand away from their host's
overly warm handshake, as the host tries their
best to express regret and salvage the failed
meeting.
Why does the visitor chuckle on their way
out, promising themselves never to visit this odd
person again?
And yet, at the same time, they can't
help but imagine that the host's face, during
their conversation, looked exactly like a poor kitten,
caught by some mischievous children, roughly handled, scared,
and teased until, utterly humiliated, it hides under
a chair in the dark.
There it bristles up, hisses, and washes its
face with its little paws, sulking over its
ordeal and glaring at the world, even at
the scraps of food the kind housekeeper left
for it.
Wait, Nastenka interrupted, her eyes wide and her
little mouth open in surprise as she listened
to me.
Wait.
I don't know why all that happened, or
why you're asking me such ridiculous questions.
All I know is, this must have happened
to you exactly like that.
Doubtless, I replied with the most serious expression.
Well, since there's no doubt about it, go
on, said Nastenka, because I really want to
know how it all ends.
You want to know, Nastenka, what our hero,
that is, me, since I was the hero
of the whole affair, was doing in his
little corner?
You want to know why the unexpected visit
of a friend left me so flustered, why
I felt upset the entire day?
You want to know why I completely lost
my composure, why I blushed when the door
opened, why I was so incapable of hosting
my visitor, and why I crumbled under the
weight of my own hospitality?
Yes, yes, Nastenka responded eagerly.
That's exactly it.
You're describing it all so wonderfully, but couldn't
you maybe tone it down just a little?
You sound like you're reading a story straight
out of a book.
Nastenka, I said in a mock serious tone,
trying not to laugh.
Dear Nastenka, I know I describe things splendidly,
but forgive me, I don't know how else
to do it.
Right now, Nastenka, I feel like the spirit
of King Solomon when, after being locked away
in an urn sealed with seven seals for
a thousand years, those seals were finally broken.
At this moment, after we've met, after such
a long separation because I feel I've known
you forever, Nastenka, right now, it feels as
if a thousand valves have opened in my
head.
Words are pouring out of me like a
river, and if I don't let them flow,
I think I might burst.
So I beg you, Nastenka, don't interrupt me,
just listen patiently, or else I'll have to
stop.
No, no, no, please, don't stop, go on,
I won't say a word.
All right, then, I'll continue.
There is, Nastenka, a certain hour of the
day that I love more than any other.
It's the hour when most people have finished
their work or errands, when they're hurrying home
for dinner, to relax, to rest, or to
think about the pleasant moments their free time
might bring.
At that hour, our hero—yes, allow me to
speak about myself—in the third person, since it
feels too embarrassing to tell it in the
first person, would join the others heading home,
but on his face, pale and a bit
crumpled, there was a strange expression of happiness.
He wasn't indifferent to the fading glow of
the sunset over the cold Petersburg sky, though
he didn't consciously notice it, either.
It was more like he saw it without
realizing, as though he were distracted by something
far more interesting.
He was happy because until the next day
he was free from the tedious responsibilities that
weighed on him.
He felt as joyful as a schoolboy let
loose after class, ready to dive into games
and harmless mischief.
If you had seen him then, Nastenka, you
would have noticed how joy flickered across his
face, already affecting his sensitive nerves and overly
vivid imagination.
He wasn't thinking about dinner or the evening
ahead.
No, he was lost in his own private
world.
Look at him, Nastenka.
He's rich now, rich with his inner life.
The golden light of the setting sun warms
his heart and stirs a swarm of impressions.
He barely notices the road beneath his feet
or the little details that might usually catch
his attention.
The goddess of fancy, if you've read Zhukovsky,
Nastenka, has already begun spinning her threads, weaving
patterns of magical, enchanting life.
Who knows?
Perhaps she has carried him far away, to
some shimmering dreamland, leaving the ordinary world behind.
Stop him now, ask him where he's going,
and he wouldn't know.
He'd probably blush with embarrassment and make up
an excuse, anything to avoid admitting he was
lost in his thoughts.
That's why he jumps in surprise when a
kind old lady stops him on the street
to ask for directions.
Irritated at being pulled back to reality, he
strides off again, barely noticing how passers-by
glance curiously at him.
A little girl stepping aside to avoid him,
giggles at his distracted smile and odd gestures.
But even these interruptions, Nastenka, are caught by
his imagination and spun into the whimsical tapestry
of his thoughts.
When he finally returns to his quiet little
den, his mind is overflowing with new impressions.
Matrona, his sombre and dutiful housekeeper, clears away
his dinner, which he barely remembers eating.
The room grows dark.
The colourful kingdom of his fantasies crumbles into
silence, like a fading dream he can't quite
recall.
Yet his heart aches with a strange, tender
longing.
Something stirs within him, teasing his imagination to
build new dreams.
As the house grows still, his solitude feeds
his thoughts.
A book lies abandoned in his lap, forgotten
after just a few pages.
His mind has already begun crafting a new
world, filled with fresh adventures and delicate emotions.
What does he care about real life, Nastenka?
To him it seems dull, lifeless, slow—nothing like
the vivid, enchanting world of his dreams.
And yet, Nastenka, even as he loses himself
in these dreams, a day may come when
he'd trade all of them for just one
moment of real, imperfect life.
Perhaps he doesn't foresee it yet, but one
day the hour may strike when he would
give anything to escape his illusions and grasp
something real.
But for now, he's content to live as
the artist of his own existence, creating a
new life for himself, every hour.
When I finished my heartfelt appeal, I paused,
letting my words hang in the air, feeling
as though my emotions had poured out too
pathetically.
At that moment I had an intense urge
to force myself to laugh, to brush it
all off as a joke, but I couldn't.
I could feel something deep and painful stirring
within me, a malignant demon of self-awareness.
There was a lump forming in my throat,
my chin was beginning to quiver, and my
eyes were slowly welling with tears that I
struggled to hold back.
I glanced at Nastenka, who had been listening
intently, her clever eyes wide with curiosity.
I expected her to break into one of
her innocent, irrepressible laughs, the kind that could
bring lightness to even the heaviest moment.
I braced myself for it, even regretting how
far I had let my confession go.
Why had I opened myself up so completely?
Why had I poured out what had been
simmering in my heart for so long?
These were thoughts I had turned over endlessly
in my mind, passed judgment on long ago,
and here I was reliving them as though
reading from a well-rehearsed script.
I had made my confession, not expecting understanding,
but simply unable to keep it inside any
longer.
But to my surprise, Nastenka didn't laugh.
Instead, she remained silent, her expression softening with
something far more meaningful.
She waited a moment, as if searching for
the right words, and then faintly pressed my
hand.
Her touch was light, filled with timid sympathy.
Finally, in a voice that trembled with concern,
she asked, Surely, you haven't lived like that
all your life?
All my life, Nastenka, I replied, my voice
heavy with resignation.
All my life.
And it feels as though I'm destined to
live that way until the very end.
No, that won't do, she said quickly, her
uneasiness plain.
That must not be.
And if I think about it, maybe I'll
spend my whole life beside my grandmother, too.
But do you know?
It's not right to live like that.
It's not good.
I know, Nastenka, I know, I cried, no
longer able to restrain my emotions.
And now I realize it more than ever.
I see it so clearly, so painfully.
I've wasted my best years, thrown them away,
and now, sitting here beside you, I feel
it with an ache I can hardly bear.
It's as if God himself sent you to
me, my good angel, to tell me the
truth, to show me what I've lost.
Here I am, talking with you, and it
feels strange, even impossible, to think about the
future.
Because when I think of the future, I
see nothing but loneliness again.
I see the same stale, useless life waiting
for me, and it horrifies me.
What will I have to dream of, then,
when for these two evenings I've known real
happiness?
Sitting beside you, talking with you, this has
been real.
What will become of me when this is
gone?
I paused, overwhelmed by my own words, and
for a moment I feared they might have
been too much.
But Nastenka's reaction was immediate and sincere.
Tears sparkled in her eyes as she shook
her head vehemently.
Oh, no, no, she cried, her voice filled
with emotion.
It can't be like that anymore.
It mustn't be.
We can't just part like this.
What are two evenings?
Two evenings are nothing.
Oh, Nastenka, Nastenka, do you realize how much
you've helped me make peace with myself?
Do you understand that because of you I
might finally stop looking at myself with such
disdain during those dark moments when I loathe
everything about my life?
Do you know that you may even help
me let go of the weight of guilt
I've carried for so long, the feeling that
my life itself has been a crime and
a sin?
And don't think for a second, Nastenka, don't
think I'm exaggerating.
I'm telling you the plain truth.
At times, a misery so deep takes hold
of me, a misery I can hardly explain
to anyone, a misery that feels endless.
It's during those times, Nastenka, that I begin
to believe I'm incapable of starting a real
life, of living in the world as it
is.
It feels as if I've lost all connection
to the actual, the tangible, the real.
I've cursed myself for it over and over
again.
After my long nights of fantasy, I wake
to moments of clarity so brutal, so sobering,
that they are almost unbearable.
It's then that the world of life around
me becomes deafening, the sounds of people living
real lives, moving forward, creating meaning.
I hear them, I see them, and I
realize their lives aren't slipping away like dreams
or fleeting visions.
Their days aren't hollow, they're full of purpose,
ever-changing, eternally renewing themselves, each hour different
from the last.
And then there's me, with my imagination, which
feels so lifeless, so repetitive, so uninspired.
My fancy is a slave to shadows and
fleeting ideas, shackled to the smallest cloud that
dims the sun.
And you know how a Petersburg heart yearns
for sunlight, don't you, Nastenka?
But when that sun disappears, imagination becomes powerless,
crushed under the weight of its own dullness.
Fancy, which once seemed boundless, becomes tired, exhausted
even, as if it's been worn out from
too much use.
And then you realize, Nastenka, that you've outgrown
your dreams, that the ideals you once cherished
are crumbling, shattering into dust.
And yet what else can you do but
try to build something new from the broken
pieces?
All the while your soul craves something else,
something real, something it cannot name.
And yet in vain the dreamer searches through
his old dreams, hoping to find a spark
among the ashes, just one ember to reignite
the fire, to warm his cold heart once
more.
He tries to revive that sweet, intoxicating feeling
that once made his blood race and his
eyes fill with tears, that once deceived him
so beautifully.
But it's all for nothing.
Do you understand, Nastenka, what I've come to?
Do you know what I do now, out
of sheer desperation?
I celebrate the anniversaries of my feelings, yes,
anniversaries of things that never truly happened.
I mark the dates of those foolish, shadowy
dreams that I once believed in, dreams that
no longer exist because I've lost the power
to create them.
Even dreams, you see, require effort.
They don't come for free.
And now I find myself revisiting the places
where I once felt happy in my own
way.
I try to piece together my present life
from the fragments of an unchangeable past.
Like a ghost, I wander the streets and
alleys of Petersburg, aimless and sad, searching for
memories.
Do you know what it's like, Nastenka, to
stand on a familiar street and remember that
a year ago to the day you were
there, just as lonely, just as lost?
And yet, somehow, it feels as though things
were better then, even though they weren't.
Back then, your dreams might have been sad,
but they weren't haunted by the black thoughts
that torment you now.
You didn't feel the relentless gnawing of conscience,
that gloomy, unyielding guilt that eats away at
you day and night.
And you ask yourself, where have all my
dreams gone?
You shake your head and think about how
quickly the years have flown by.
And then comes the awful question.
What have you done with your time?
Where have you buried your best days?
Have you even truly lived?
And so you look around and see how
cold the world has become.
You think about how, in just a few
more years, solitude will close in completely.
Then will come old age, creeping in with
its trembling hands, and after that misery, desolation.
Your imagined world will fade.
Your dreams will die and fall like autumn
leaves from the trees, leaving you utterly alone.
Oh, Nastenka, can you imagine what it will
feel like to reach that point, to look
back and find you have nothing, absolutely nothing,
to regret because everything you've lost was never
real in the first place?
Can you imagine realizing that all you've ever
had were dreams, foolish, empty dreams?
Come now, don't stir up my feelings anymore,
said Nastenka, brushing away a tear that had
slipped down her cheek.
It's enough, it's all over now.
From this moment we're together, two of us.
Whatever happens to me, we won't be separated.
Do you hear me?
We'll never part.
Listen, she continued, her voice soft but filled
with resolve.
I'm just a simple girl.
I haven't had much education, though Grandmother did
hire a teacher for me for a while,
but I do understand you, truly, I do.
Everything you've just described, I felt it too.
I went through the same thing when Grandmother
pinned me to her dress to keep me
by her side.
Of course, she added shyly, a faint blush
coloring her cheeks.
I couldn't have described it the way you
did.
You've said it so beautifully.
I'm not educated enough to speak like that,
she admitted timidly, her voice carrying a note
of respect for what she called my pathetic
eloquence and lofty style.
But still, I'm glad, so very glad that
you've been so open with me.
Now I feel like I know you completely,
every part of you.
She paused, her dark eyes studying me closely,
as if seeing me for the first time
in a new light.
And do you know what, she said, her
tone shifting to one of quiet determination.
I want to tell you my story too,
everything with no secrets.
After that, you must promise to give me
advice.
You're so clever.
Will you promise to help me figure things
out?
Ah, Nastenka, I exclaimed, feeling a surge of
emotion at her trust.
I've never been much good at giving advice,
sensible advice, least of all.
But seeing us here now, like this, I
feel as though, if we always stay this
way, together, we'll both end up giving each
other plenty of good advice, sensible or not.
Tell me, my dear Nastenka, what kind of
advice do you need?
Speak openly.
Right now I'm so happy, so light-hearted,
so bold and clear-headed that I feel
like I could find the right words for
anything.
No, no, Nastenka interrupted, laughing warmly, her earlier
tears already forgotten.
I don't just want sensible advice, I want
advice that's warm and kind, advice that feels
like it's coming from an older brother who
has cared about me my whole life.
That's the kind of advice I need?
Agreed, Nastenka, agreed, I cried, delighted by her
request.
And let me tell you this, if I
had known you all my life, if I
had cared about you for twenty years, I
still couldn't feel any fonder of you than
I do now.
Give me your hand, said Nastenka, her voice
steady and filled with meaning.
Here it is, I replied, placing my hand
in hers without hesitation.
She held it for a moment, her fingers
gripping mine firmly, as if to seal some
unspoken promise between us.
Then she smiled, a smile so full of
hope and trust that it seemed to light
up the dim, quiet street around us.
And now, she said, her voice soft but
filled with anticipation, Let's begin my story.